[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
YACINE REZGUI: Next
billion users, or NBU,
are countries where half
of the population or more
is not connected
yet to the internet.
They have a different
way to interact
with the internet, a different
way to use their smartphone.
And we're going to highlight
you all those cases
in this presentation.
First, let's have a
situation on the ground.
As you can see, the
next billion users
are spread out, three
different continents--
Asia, Africa, and Latin America.
For some of them,
internet is just
the beginning of a new era.
We usually think about the
next billion users as something
in the future, something
which is not ready yet.
As shown on the map,
numerous countries
already part of the internet.
Some countries in Asia
as a whole region account
for 50% of the
smartphone market--
Vietnam, Philippines,
Indonesia, they
are part of the
Southeast Asia, which
accounts for 350 million
users on the internet.
And India itself accounts for
40 million new users every year.
Again, we usually think
as the next billion users
that we have a timeline, we
have a time to think about it.
It's already big.
It's already present,
and just continue
to be bigger and bigger
in the upcoming years.
For them, phone is
not only a device
to connect to the internet,
it's the only device
they will have access to you.
So you should not
expect your users
to have access to a
computer or tablet
to access your applications.
They have a mobile-only mindset.
And, as an example,
Nigeria has only 11%
of the population having
access to a computer.
They have an instinct
for ubiquitous computing.
In India, 30% of the search
made on Google are using voice.
It's not a net case, it's not
a power user thing to do there.
It's really normal.
They have natural interaction
with the smartphone.
They will use it in
all the possible ways.
Lastly, they have a huge
demand for localized content.
English is the first
language on the internet,
but it doesn't mean it's
a language understood
by all the users over there.
They don't only want
translated content.
They want content adapted
for them-- for their culture,
their environment.
Also, you should expect users
to change their language quite
often based on the environment--
Maybe at work with
family, with friends,
based on that current location.
They will just continuously
change language.
It's not something
rare for them.
It's really often.
As shown on the map, numerous
countries who are NBU
are part of Asia and Africa.
Both continents accounts
for 119 official languages.
In India, you have
314 million people
who can speak two languages
and sometimes even more.
Again, in India, you had 23
official languages written
in 13 different scripts.
It brings some challenges
in terms of content display
and font-swapping.
Hindi, which is one of the
official languages in India,
is not even on the top
30 languages in the web,
even though it's the
fourth most spoken language
around the world.
Nigeria itself as a country
has 500 spoken languages
around the whole country.
Even though English may be
the official language there,
people will use their local
language because, again, it's
part of their culture.
You cannot deny that.
Also, they have another
diversity in terms of hardware.
They will have different
devices, different brands.
And you have to account
for them whenever you are
developing your application.
Some of them you may
already know, some OEMs.
Obviously Samsung is there.
But also some Chinese
OEMs, as Huawei,
Oppo, OnePlus, and Xiaomi.
In Nigeria, you
have also Everyone.
And in India, you have MicroMax.
Transsion is the first Android
Go OEM around the world.
And maybe you've
never heard of it.
They have commonly
lower specs devices,
but you should not
target only those.
You should think about
it as a spectrum.
Some people may have higher spec
devices, some of them lower,
and you have to account
for all of them.
Lastly, they have long
wear hardware upgrade.
You should think
about it whenever
you estimate your operational
costs developing an application
targeting those markets.
We usually think about
offline as a narrow state.
You're in a plane, in a
train, in a building where
the signal is not strong.
Well actually, it can
be a choice for them.
Offline usually is just
a temporary mistake,
the way we think about
it in Western countries.
But in those NBU
countries, 95% of the users
are on prepaid plans.
Even though 4G and
3G is definitely
cheaper years after years,
people just turn it off
whenever they don't need it.
So whenever you're showing a
banner, you're not connected,
well, they're
already aware of it.
They are the one who set it off.
Also, Wi-Fi is not
always reliable.
So you can't expect people
to download resources
over Wi-Fi because they
may not have it at home.
Sometimes 4G is even
faster than Wi-Fi.
Some websites may
be also offered
for free, on mobile
plans, or restricted
by government regulation.
So whenever you're integrating
with third parties,
think about it whenever
you're developing your apps
targeting those markets.
We usually think about
diversity as a problem,
as just too many
parameters to account for.
We would love just to
have one single standard
but that's just denying
their diversity.
We think diversity at Google is
not a problem, it's an asset.
It's a growth opportunity
for your markets.
As shown earlier, again,
many countries which are NBUs
are part of Asia,
which already accounts
for 50% of the smartphone
market and will
account for 50% of
the upcoming growth
on the smartphone market.
You have to compare
that to mature markets
like Western countries
where you have
already a huge penetration of
internet and smartphone access.
Over the next 1.6
billion new connections,
40% will come from these
top five countries.
Four of them are
next billion users--
Nigeria, India,
Pakistan, and Indonesia.
Also, the surrounding
countries will
be affected by that growth.
So again, think about it, the
next billion users are already
there.
And they're just
waiting for your apps
to be compatible with them.
Now I'm going to hand over
to my colleague, Rajeev--
Amrit, my bad-- is going
to talk about improving
your application by adopting
Google products that
can help you to do that.
To you, Amrit.
AMRIT SANJEEV: Thanks, Yacine.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Amrit Sanjeev.
I'm a developer advocate
at Google based in India.
And, in this section, I
want to talk about some
of the Google products
that you can use in order
to help give a better user
experience for your users
in the NBU market.
Let's start with app bundles.
App size is a key
factor that users
consider when they install
an app in these markets.
By switching an upload
format to app bundles,
you allow player to
distribute an APK that's
optimized in terms of
resources, code, and languages
based on your device's
configuration.
This helps greatly reduce
the initial install size
of the application and
also the install friction
that users have.
I want to call out
an example here--
RedBus, which is a
ticket-booking app from India
who switched over
to app bundle format
and reduced their
APK size by 30%.
This, in turn, helped them
increase their conversions
by 6%.
And the best part
of it is that they
didn't have to change
a single line of code
to achieve this result.
To optimize even
further, you can
choose to deliver
functionality as on-demand
rather than package
it all together
in the initial install.
This can be achieved by
using the on-demand feature
with app bundles.
By adopting on-demand
features, you
not only reduce the
initial install size,
but also the space that you
actually take on the device.
A lot of users run out of space
on devices in these regions
regularly.
The other important factor
is that based on usage,
you can choose to remove modules
and save space for the user.
An example I want to
call out is PayTM,
who initially reduced their
app size using app bundles
and then further optimized by
removing some of their modules
as on-demand modules,
and reduced the app
size by a further 20%.
And they're not done yet.
They're making further changes
and improving on this number
even further.
To extend this even further, you
could use conditional modules
to install certain modules
based on your device
configuration or user's locale
during the initial install.
Let me explain this with
an example for you guys.
Assume that you have an app
which you want to release it
to two different countries.
But in each of
these countries, you
have completely different
payment instruments
of support, which would
mean that you would have
completely different workflows,
assets, and libraries required
for realizing each of
the payment workflows.
One way of doing this would
be to package all of this
into a single payment
module and, at runtime,
decide which workflow
to show to the user
depending on which locale
he is using the app from.
With conditional modules,
you could actually
separate this into two different
modules and during install time
decide which module needs to
be packaged with the app based
on the user's locale.
That way your device
would only get
the portions of code and the
workflow that it will ever use.
The second payment module
will not be there at all.
As Yacine mentioned,
BOU countries
have a lot of
official languages.
For example India, has
23 official languages.
But the interesting
thing here to note
is that users usually set their
device language to be English.
And it's a very common
practice for applications
which cater for these markets
to have an in-app setting where
users choose the language
for localizing content
on their app.
Now, when you take app
bundles for instance,
app bundles use
the device language
to optimize what
language resources need
to be packaged along with the
APK during the installation.
And with language
splits API, you actually
bring the best of both worlds.
Using this API, the
developed can then
fetch additional
language resources
for different
languages, say, when
the user is selecting a new
language from the settings.
I talked about install
size for some time.
Let's talk about how app
upgrades happen in this region.
App upgrade cycles
are usually longer,
which means you will end up
having situations where you
will have more versions of
your app in the real world
to support.
This has side effects.
It not only increases
your operational cost,
but you have to deal
with situations where
users negatively rate
your app for bugs
you have already fixed.
But they are still
experiencing it
because they never upgraded it.
Now, in in-app upgrade API helps
you fix some of these problems.
It allows you to show a dialog
to the user informing them
that a new update is available.
The best part of this
API that it actually
takes into account the
player's targeting rules
before showing it to the user.
That is, if your stage
is rolling out only 5%
of your users, only
those 5% of users
actually see the upgrade dialog.
It's the same case with people
who are on a different channel,
say your alpha channel
of your application.
And you release only to
alpha, only those users
will actually see this.
I want to now
switch over to SMS.
Two-factor authentication is
very common in NBU countries.
This is because a lot
of payment modules
are actually two-factor
authentication based.
And more and more
applications are
requesting for SMS
permission to ensure
that they can make the OTP
flow much more smoother
by auto-filling it for the user.
But with growing privacy
concerns, a lot of users
are reluctant to give
this permission, and also
worried about how much
information they're
passing to an app by giving them
complete access to their SMS
inbox.
Last year, we introduced SMS
Retriever API, which kind of
solved this problem
to a good extent,
where an OTP message could be
passed through an application
without the user
giving this permission.
But it required the
SMS message to be
formatted in a certain way.
To be more precise, it a hash
code towards the end of it,
which allowed the
API to identify
that the particular
OTP message is
for a particular application.
That's great when
the SMS are sent
by the application's service.
But imagine a case of
a bank application.
They have to deal with
hundreds of applications
or thousands of them.
And in such cases, you
will have to do a look-up
to figure out
which hash code has
to be attached to the
end of the message
before you send it
out to the client.
And that's kind of inefficient.
So that's where the SMS and
the API comes into the picture.
The workflow remains
pretty much the same.
But in this case, when
the OTP is actually
received on the device,
that is the OTP message
is on the device, the
system would recognize
using some smarts-that hey,
this is an OTP message,
and short dialog to
the user asking him
permission to pass that
message to the application.
If the user approves
it, the OTP message
is passed to the application,
and the rest of the flow
can automatically continue.
The advantage here is that there
is no additional formatting
required.
There's no SMS permission
required for this.
I want to call out
an example here,
of Zomato, which is a food
delivery and restaurant booking
app from the region, which
was able to remove SMS read
permission completely from their
application by using this API.
They were part of our
early access program.
And they've reported to us
that their user flow has now
improved in speed and users are
having a much better experience
because of this.
Moving on to real
world performance,
no matter where you're
launching your app,
understanding the real world
performance of your app
is really important
once you ship it.
But it's even more critical
in NBU markets because
of the plethora of
devices available there
and the wide range of
conditions, hardware,
network situations
prevalent in these regions.
Firebase Performance
Monitoring SDK
is one such SDK that you can
add to your app, which will then
collect statistics
automatically,
visualizes it, and
even identifies
and highlights problems for you.
This allows you to fix problems
before users actually see this,
giving a better
experience for your users.
I want to highlight the
work that [INAUDIBLE] apps
did with data that they actually
derived from these Firebase
Performance consults.
They were able to reduce
their apps cold start-up time
by 50% for users
on the 2G network.
And this gave a great
experience for those users.
They used the data that was
visualized by Firebase Console
and identified an
issue with which
was particularly happening
on 2G networks, and fix this,
immediately giving a better
experience for the users.
And lastly, I want to
talk about localization.
When we talk about localization,
a lot of times people
think about the
language in which
the content is shown on the
device or within the app.
Now, that's absolutely
important-- no doubt.
But there are other things
that you can do in this aspect.
You could use things like
localized graphics and store
listings based on the user's
language and Play Console.
This helps improve
conversions for your app.
We have recently introduced
country-based targeting, which,
again, is targeted
towards using--
targeted towards improving
user conversions for your apps.
One of our early access
partners, Cookbook
actually increased
conversion rates
by 17% using this feature.
If you want to understand
more about what they did,
they wrote an excellent
blog about it.
And you should check that out.
And, lastly, I want to
call out that this is not
an exhaustive list of
products you can use.
I've only called out
a few of them here,
which basically has
given a lot of advantages
to some of our partners who
cater for these regions.
Now I'd like to hand it over
to my colleague Rajeev, who
talk to you about
how to optimize
apps for low-end devices.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RAJEEV KUMAR: Thank you.
Thanks, Amrit.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Rajeev Kumar.
I work on Android Go project.
And Android Go is a platform
for devices running 1GB or less
RAM, minimum eight gigs
of internal storage,
and low-end CPU codes.
Today, I'm going to talk about
some of the best practices
that me and my team has used
to optimize apps on disk,
to optimize the apps on RAM.
And I'm also going to talk
about some of the techniques
we use to keep apps responsive.
So let's talk about APK size.
Why does APK size matter?
It matters because it
impacts the time it
takes to load your application.
It also impacts the RAM it
And it also impacts
the battery it
takes to load your application.
So what can you do to reduce
your APK size on disk?
Use Proguarding.
It really helps.
We have used Proguarding on
systems apps like Launcher
and Bluetooth APK.
And just by enabling
Proguarding,
we were able to gain
around 25% of disk space.
But [INAUDIBLE] your public
API and Proguard flags the
file so that you don't wipe
it out with Proguarding.
So how could you learn more
about your API structure?
We have used
APKAnalyzer tool to look
at what part of application is
contributing to the APK size.
And let's say you determine
the APK size was bigger
because of the
resources, you would
be able to use Shrink Resources
together with [INAUDIBLE]
Enable in your [INAUDIBLE]
project to reduce your APK
size significantly.
What else you can do?
You may consider to
use specific densities.
For example, you can target
MDPI for certain devices
and therefore not include
resources for higher density.
As Amrit mentioned,
the app bundles
could also help to
reduce your APK size
or your initial download size.
Let's take an example.
The Photos app can have the
viewing capability as well as
the editing capability.
You may decide to not
include editor to begin with,
and only download the
reader module when
a user clicks on the editing
part of the application.
You may also consider
to use reduced set up
language in your application,
and therefore your resources
is going to be smaller,
and APK size is
going to be a smaller as well.
Now, continuing on the theme
of reducing your APK size,
let's talk about the MA
size in your application.
How can you reduce MA
size in your application?
Consider compressing PNG and
JPEG, crunching PNG files,
and, if possible,
use WebP file format,
which is great on
saving the disk size
and has a decent
rendering performance.
You may consider to
use vector graphics
for reducing independent
icons in a scalable media.
By doing so, you would not be
including the static resources.
And, therefore, your APK size
is going to be a smaller.
What else you can do?
Avoid enumerations.
A single enum can take
up to 1 to 1.4 kilobytes
size in your cluster
to desk file.
If possible, use [INAUDIBLE]
with Proguarding, and it
will replace your enumeration
built into your constants.
Remove debug symbol from
your native binaries.
They are great for
developing your application.
However, it can take
significant amount of APK size.
And, while extracting
native libraries,
by doing so, you will be
instructing packet manager
to not to copy .SO file from
your application to the file
system.
And as a nice side
effect, your update size
is going to be a smaller.
Now I want to talk about how
to reduce your app size in RAM.
So how would you monitor
your app size in RAM?
Use Android Compiler, which
comes with Android Studio,
to generate heap dump
for your application.
You may also use
the ADB command,
which is ADB shell am dumpheap
to generate Java heap dump as
well as native heap dump.
And with the debug working
on your application
and with these heap dumps, you
would have a pretty good idea
about what part of
your application
is contributing to the RAM size.
So let's say system is
under memory pressure.
What can you do to reduce
memory pressure on the system?
For this, the activity
manager service
provides a callback called
on prem memory, which
you can implement
in your activity
and can release resources
and cache objects
to reduce memory
pressure on the system.
What else?
Do not create
unnecessary processes
unless they are short-lived.
Long-lived processes can
contribute to the memory
of your application.
Use services sparingly.
If possible, consider
using Java Scribbler,
which is constraint-aware.
It can take into account
the system memory
pressure, the
network conditions,
as well as the battery.
Consider using optimized
data containers, which
are array map, array set, sparse
array, sparse Boolean array,
longest sparse array.
These are optimized for
using memory efficiently,
and can save your app
to have less RAM size.
Continuing on the theme of
reducing APK size in RAM,
you should consider
avoiding memory churn
by reducing the number of
garbage collection events
to occur.
And for this, you should
avoid allocating objects
in the performance-critical
area of your application.
And those areas are on layout,
on draw, on major, et cetera.
I talked about reducing
the memory churn
by reducing the number
of garbage collection.
It not only impacts
the memory but it also
can impact your
app responsiveness
by eating your app's frame.
So now in this slide I'm
going to talk about how
to keep your app responsive.
And, for that, start
with do not drop data.
Let's say you are
an email application
in which [INAUDIBLE]
composing an email,
and some other
application saves on top.
In this case, you
want to save data
so that when your application
comes back again on top,
you want it to store data so
that user does not lose data.
Do not expose raw data.
Consider using content provider,
which is the consistent way
to sell your data
across application,
within your application as well.
Do not interrupt user.
Consider not to call
a start activity
from broadcast receiver or
from a background service.
If possible, consider using
notification manager to set up
a notification to which you can
come back to your application
by looking at that notification.
Got a lot to do?
Consider doing it in a thread,
maybe in a background thread
to avoid any long-running
processes running
in your main thread.
If possible, you
may also consider
to use the JavaScribbler
for the processes which are
going to take longer duration.
As I mentioned earlier,
it is constraint-aware
and can scribble your job when
system is processing your job.
Do not overload signal
activity for the devices of--
devices.
You may consider
your application
as a federation of activity.
And by doing so, you would
be making your application
more maintainable.
And, as a nice side
effect, it will work well
with the application history
and the backstretch model.
Continuing on the theme of
keeping your app responsive,
design your UI so that it works
with different screen sizes.
Your resources, your images
sort of scale up and down based
on the screen sizes.
And, lastly, do
conserve device battery.
A mobile device is not so
mobile if it is constantly
connected to the wall charger.
Two of the main contributors
of the battery drain
are the processor
and the radio signal.
So it's important to do as
little processing as possible
and to use network as
infrequently as possible.
Now, this brings the
end of our presentation.
But by no means this
is the [INAUDIBLE] list
of techniques and
best practices you
may use in your application.
To learn about the full list
of practices and techniques,
you can go to developer.androi
d.com/performance.
We hope this presentation may
have helped you to learn more
about the techniques
you can use for making
your application have a
level for next billion users.
Thanks a lot.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]